- [Lecturer] We're told that
a ball attached to a string
swings in a horizontal
circle at constant speed
as shown below.
The string makes an angle
theta with the horizontal.
Which arrows show all
the forces on the ball?
So pause this video, and see
if you can figure that out.
Okay, so let's work through this together.
So this ball is attached to the string,
and it's currently hanging down,
and I think it's fair to say
that we are on some type of a planet.
And so, if we're on some type of planet,
you're definitely gonna
have the force of gravity
acting on the ball, so
let me draw that vector.
So the force of gravity,
I'll do in orange.
Let's say it looks something like that.
Its magnitude, I'll denote as capital F
with a sub g right over here.
Now what's keeping that ball
from accelerating downwards?
And also, what's keeping that ball
in this uniform circular motion?
And the answer to both of those questions
is the tension in the rope.
Remember, tension is a pulling force.
The rope is pulling on this ball.
And so, we could say the force
of the tension, so it might
look something like this,
the force, force of the tension.
Now just with that, we have
constructed a free body diagram,
and we can immediately
answer their question,
what are the forces that
are acting on the ball,
which arrows show it.
So there is one downwards,
and then there is one going in
the direction of the string,
and if you look at these choices here,
you would say it is that
one right over there.
Now some of you might say,
"Wait, hold on a second.
"Isn't there some type
of a centripetal force
"that keeps the ball going in a circle,
"that keeps it from
just going straight off?
"And then isn't there some type of force
"that counteracts the
actual force of gravity?"
And the answer to the
question is yes, there is
but those are really just
components of the tension.
And so, if you look at the
X component of the tension,
I'll do that in a blue
color right over here,
this X component of the tension,
so I'll call that F sub Tx,
that is our centripetal force,
or that its magnitude of
the X component of tension
is the same thing as the magnitude
of our centripetal force.
If we look at the Y
component of our tension,
the Y component of our tension,
that's what counteracts
the force of gravity.
So this right over here,
its magnitude is F sub Ty,
and F sub Ty, this magnitude
is going to be the same thing
as the magnitude of the force of gravity.
But we already answered our question,
and we just got a little
bit more intuition
of what's going on right over here.